back in the day yes uh when we're doing
the Late Night show it was fun you you
sort of you you were sort of a friend of
the show you would hang out there yeah
enjoy everything in the whole yeah and
and one of our great writers Mr Kevin
dorf and you would you would hang out
with us and um you said you actually
came to a really early show well now
here's my situation with you in this
show is there's a little bit of like uh
a post-traumatic situation happening
when I have to see you and you've been
nice enough to have me and see when I
was like 15 years old I was in
Rockefeller Center with a girlfriend and
we were on mushrooms
um and I just remember I was like so I
wasn't really like Showbiz yet you know
I was just in Rockefeller Center on
mushrooms and
um and they like someone ushers me and
they go come this way so we follow you
know as you do and suddenly we were
inside uh the studio audience of a very
early taping and actually you sort of
look different because I remember at the
time just being like sort of suddenly
horrified by this thing we stepped into
that was like No Exit you know because
we didn't really they slammed the doors
and out comes just like a test show me
or like a really early version of our
show yeah okay this is like many uh
years ago it's like 20 years ago yeah
yeah and uh and you come out and you're
just like seven feet tall and like neon
orange and you just now this is the part
I can't recall for sure is were you
singing Elvis to warm up the crowd yeah
there was this whole period of time
where I would come out and before the
the show warm up yeah you know now we
have this great guy Jimmy Pardo comes
out and warms up the crowd and does an
amazing job back then we didn't know
what the hell we were doing and people
were like how are we gonna warp the
crowd and be like I guess I'll sing them
a tune
come out and I would full-on do a
hyperactive Elvis Presley show for the
whole crowd yeah I liked it then I'd go
back and I came out every night for the
monologue out of breath and sweating
because I had done my own warm-up like
an idiot suffice to say it was
terrifying terrifying I mean but really
yes yeah that was the goal to terrify
the crowd oh it worked I mean it went
from like Willy Wonka to Jacob's Ladder
but quick
so that's a horrifying memory yeah it is
I really got a face coming in at you
yeah those are the days those were the
days those were the days good God uh
well now you're doing orange yeah Orange
is the New Black uh this show uh is a
people love it people absolutely love it
and you do such a great job but we have
a clip here uh to tell us which scene uh
I believe it's in prison yes uh having
not seen the clip I um I think it's
almost there in prison it's going to be
in prison yeah and uh I think this is
like an early on this is like an early
intro I believe this is where the main
character maybe misspeaks about the food
in prison which is not a wise thing to
do no no don't do that when you go to
prison don't do that
yeah it's like with this clip from
Orange is the New Black